All 41 workers who were trapped in a collapsed
Himalayan tunnel have now been rescued.
I can give you a look once again at the exterior
of the tunnel that we've been closely watching
where those construction workers were stuck,
of course, for the last 17 days.
We're looking at a final ambulance it seems
outside of the tunnel entrance.
Let's get back to vedika sud in New Delhi.
Vedika, it's tough to find words to emphasize
the relief of the success of the 17-day mission.
It's had plenty of setbacks.
The relief of the officials there, the families,
and indeed the workers themselves, that for
the first time in 17 days, breathing fresh
air.
We >> Absolutely, it is nothing short of a
miracle.
That is what a lot of officials on the ground
would say.
But you know we want to
[10:50:50 AM]
But you know we want to acknowledge the achievement
of the state as well.
The biggest challenge they face was the machine,
it was a how heavy drilling machine that broke
down repeatedly.
The last two meters that we covered today
was through manual drilling.
They sent scores of rescue teams inside that
drilled through the debris, drilled through
the middle.
This is an ecologically fragile area.
This tunnel collapsed partially because of
a landslide and this rubble in debris was
of course unstable and on unsteady ground.
It was equally dangerous sending rescue teams
inside as it would be to rescue those people
who are trapped inside.
There was scores of ambulances on standby
over the last S hours.
We anticipate a lot of movements during the
day.
That's exactly wouldappen.
That is what we've seen.
41 men have been successfully extracted from
the tunnel from
[10:51:52 AM]
extracted from the tunnel from a 50 meter
pipe which is about fifth D meters wide in
diameter.
They were pulled out after being mounted on
stretchers.
They illuminated the entire passageway of
this path to make sure that these men, who
have faced severe trauma, are pulled out gently
and reassured that they are on their way out
and on their way to safety.
Seconds later, after every man was pulled,
out they were whisked away in an ambulance
away from the rebel, Julia, away from the
debris, away from danger.
They were pulled away from uncertainty which
they had faced for 16 days.
>> A police system was used in a far smaller
pipe than you are seeing here, which is this
tunnel entrance.
Just give us a sense of what you're seeing,
it seems on the side it is curtains.
We did not really get to see the removal of
any of these workers, as we saw this
[10:52:52 AM]
workers, as we saw this operation take place
over the past hour.
They were whisked into ambulances for the
most part and taken away, even as we saw their
celebrations.
Vedika, we will hear tales of heroism that
took place the past 17 days.
In particular, as you said, when the machinery
broke, digging literally with her hands in
order to try to get to these workers.
Have we had any updates so far?
And I know that it's early.
But as you, said there was a hospital set
up inside the tunnel.
Do have an update on the health of these men?
>> I think we will have to wait a while.
Maybe overnight, perhaps.
It'slready about 9:00 here in India.
That is local time.
It's dark out there.
The priority obviously is to take them to
a medical center to assess them overnight,
to make sure that any needs are catered to
at this point.
Especially mental health as a primary focus
for the medical experts who are tending to
these men.
[10:53:53 AM]
Over the last 70 days, Julia, there have been
pipelines through which oxygen has been supplied.
Food has been supplied, initially it was dry
food, when they had a wider pipe if they started
something in cooked food.
There is water that's been sent in.
Medicines, vitamin D, mobile chargers.
They have assured that whatever they could
supply these men with through these very narrow
pipelines, medical attendants, medical supervisors
have been on a megaphone with them over the
past two weeks, they've been ex assessing
their condition, talking to them, telling
them to eat, telling them to hydrate themselves
along with a constant assurance that they
will be pulled out.
That has culminated into what we're seeing
on our screen today, which is a huge success.
Not sure -- short of a miracle.
41 men pulled, out extracted from a tunnel
that collapsed partially on the 12th of November
due to a landslide in the area.
This is a very ecological fragile region.
A lot of questions must be asked by environmentalists,
by
[10:54:55 AM]
asked by environmentalists, by ecological
experts, the government should also be held
accountable at this point for what we've seen
over the last 17 days.
It has been nothing short of a disappointment
to have these men stuck inside the tunnel.
But today there has been success and, at least
for this, moment that should be celebrated,
Julia.
>> Certainly.
You called it not far from a miracle.
Most people watching this considered a miracle,
after 17 days diminish to get food, water,
oxygen to them.
To get all 41 safely out.
Maybe we'll have to wait a few hours now until
we hear about their health.
We will keep our fingers crossed on that front.
I think we're witnessing a miracle in northern
India today, with all 41 of those workers
out.
Vedika, the families, we can only imagine.
I know you've been talking with your team
to many of them.
The sheer relief and joy at getting their
workers and family relations out safely after
17 days of what can only
[10:55:55 AM]
after 17 days of what can only